on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-hander anthony diesclafani
he's cliffoni 30 years of age in his
seventh year at the big league level six
feet tall 200 pounder this year
making start number 10 through the first
nine outstanding 4-1 with a 2-0-3 era
lifetime against these
dodgers he's 1-5 with a 4-6-5 era
originally mookie betts was going to
lead things off and play in right field
well he has been scratched as we
understand to left shoulder soreness so
this lineup has been juggled as could be
gavin lux starting it off at shortstop
this afternoon
dodgers winning 2-1 friday night 6-3
yesterday going for the sweep today and
a lead off base hit on the first pitch
from gavin lox
and so lux is sitting above 300 this
month hitting lead off for the first
time since april 11 doesn't wait around
from the wind up here's max muncie and
the pitch from diesel funny is a fly
ball to left center over to his left
is talkman and he's got it
and the inning is over just like that
it's a seven-pitch first inning
for diesel funny
now to the last of the first dodgers
nothing giants coming up on the hill
today for the dodgers will be the
left-hander julio urias urea is 24 years
of age from culiacon mexico 6-1
225-pounder in his third year at the big
league level when you take your bats
against them
you're going to see some quality stuff
he's going to give you a fastball that
goes
mid to high 90s 114 against the change
116 against the slurve
fast ball is hit sharply to turner
slater is out number one slater is out
5-3 one gone for the giants in the
bottom of the first inning
donnie barrels they call them
it's more line drives than anybody in
baseball
33 years old
17th year as a pro
swats on to right
d.j peters is there two up and two down
that was supposed to be mookie betts out
there roman right field but
came up with a little sore shoulder this
morning
taylor advances the runner and yoshi
sutsugo comes up one for 10 in a dodge
uniform so far
that's it sharply and through base it
for suzugo to give the dodgers the lead
will smith into score it's one nothing
as yoshi drives in his second run in a
dodger uniform the dodgers are just flat
out taking care of business right now
dodgers are kind of leaving him alone
letting him go back to his old swing
that he used
and boy they're starting to relax his
hands and matt's getting quicker dj
peters his first career multi-hit game
yesterday
and on a one-two pitch swings and misses
at the high fast ball two out
baby at second base tottugo at first
leo takes a pretty mean cut can't just
take him
lightly
smashes this ball and it's over yaski
in comes beatty he'll reassemble the
second the throw sells the cut off man
it scores two
julio bangs a bullet off of the wall in
right and it's three nothing dodgers
get on the edge of your seats folks this
dodger ball club talk about playing with
some confidence
he does rip at it you can't take him
lightly and he just goes jumps right on
the first pitch a very good athlete
dodgers up three nothing and are
threatening again against declining in
the giants matt beatty standing in from
the left side
fadey swings and hits it on the ground
into right field a base hit that'll get
muncie home four nothing dodgers
smith goes first to third so the dodgers
keep the line moving they've added
another here in the third inning it's
four nothing more keep it moving keep it
moving baity rolls over this ball but
the big chopper finds another hole
taylor flight out his first time first
one from biscafani is muscled into
shadow right center that'll drop in base
it for taylor to bring home one more
it is five nothing in the third inning
against a guy who hadn't given up more
than three this year diesel funny has
given up five earned runs so far the
most he has given up this season is six
so the base is full two out one one and
julio bangs one on the ground the right
side it's off the glove of rough and
everybody's gonna be safe urias with his
third run batted in beatty scores it is
six to nothing julio aureus is two for
two with three runs batted in today and
this ball was hit sharply well and guess
what they came back with a fastball base
is loaded two outs
locks hits the ball a ton
way back to right center
grand slam
just enough to get it gone
it's ten nothing and lux knew it was
gone the moment he made content second
grand slam for gavin lux this month that
will do it for anthony
munsey leading off the fourth lifting a
breaking ball deepest part of the park
and he's got enough to get it out
as max continues to swing the silver
hammer and makes it 11-nothing dodgers
breaking ball that he absolutely crushes
it gets it right out in front perfect
timing for a power swing two odds for
your scrum ski what a great day to pitch
huh you get all those runs and you're on
your game korea's fires
curveball got him looking strike three
julio strikes out the side that's 12 up
and 12 down to start the game for julio
rius maria's not only has two hits and
three runs batted in and an 11 run lead
he has not allowed a base runner the
pitch crawford drives one to right
way back but peter's way out in triples
alley makes the catch that's a hit in
any park except this one odious the
pitch
swung on and a stab by locks a diving
stab to his right to take a hit away
from mauricio dubois
15-15 down
he has faced 15 hitters he's retired
them all no hits no base runners for the
giants he has been perfect 2-2 pitch
curve ball got him looking strike three
called
16 in a row for julio urrias 2-2 to mike
talkman
is up the middle lux can't get it with a
bare hand and the giants have their
first base runner the perfect game is
gone the no hitter is gone here's the
pitch
slater drives with down the left field
line hit well and out of here so the
giants are on the board is austin slater
knocks one out of the park and it's 11-2
now they set an inside target at the
hands it's right to the glove and a
bit-arm swing facing edwin usa the
left-handed hitter against the
right-hander
the pitch on the way swing line drive
base hit over the head of the first
baseman muncie down the right field line
and into the second archway
juggers in to score slater around third
he scores yostremski's first hit of the
game a two-run double gives them
something to cheer about and he comes up
with the bases loaded two outs bottom of
the ninth dodgers leading 11 to five
santana to your shrimp skew but the 01
pitch
[Applause]
[Music]
the dodgers have swept the giants and
they've won seven in a row